I went working in a psychiatric hospital
all those years I cultivated the word
whatever yeah whatever maybe I don't
know I'm I'm not surprised by anything
anymore you're not surprised what is the
most surprising thing you saw in a
psychiatric
hospital s most intriguing in because I
saw lots of wild stuff but on the sort
of intriguing surprising side I saw a
couple of multiple personality disorder
patients sort of early in my career
where it was it was stunning how
different the different person I
literally didn't understand it was the
same person to one of the doctors
pointed out because oh yeah that was the
one you saw a couple days ago and I was
like no no no that was a different
person no same it was a different accent
different voice different just
everything incredible there have been
studies where somebody woke up from like
maybe a traumatic head injury or
something and they speak another
language or they come out of it has that
have you ever seen that I I had long Co
right yeah and uh I I had a bad case of
Co and
wh whose phone mine somebody's phone
this Siri on my phone said I figured as
much why is my why am I being interruped
sir always answer always interrup well
Siri I did have Co I'm glad you figured
that out but I I had a long Co syndrome
afterwards and I had this weird sense
that if I worked on music language or
dance it would clear it was the
strangest feeling but I thought well I
don't have patience with piano anymore
and certainly not going to dance so ah
we're going to Greece in the summer I'm
going to start working on language and
it came unusually easily and when we got
to Greece people would always stop me go
oh my God your accent is so good it's so
perfect you and you're speaking Greek
where weird Co I've never heard that it
may or may not be true side effect of it
may or may not be true all to me but it
was a weird experience some people lose
their sense of taste some people lose
their sense of smell you picked up Greek
yeah should Chinese but here's the thing
so if you had that weird vibe that you
know music dance or language and you go
I'm not going to do it but it just
happened St yeah that you were traveling
and you picked up the language and you
go oh my God this wasn't just a bizarre
feeling it was something it it was
something but why why it came
easily why aren't you dancing I should
go do Dancing with the Stars was cuz
maybe they should hear that if you're
watching Dancing with the Stars okay
next season
yeah